[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright this of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show so far hundreds of challengers
no winners we don't make mistakes
shouldn't laugh at that because it's
true tonight we've received a correction
from a gymnasium in New Jersey that
teaches the street sport of parkour take
a look oh yo look we're going in um you
hope you idiot so you did an episode
about parkour and you said parkour is
the combination of acrobatics gymnastics
and freerunning parkour is a combination
of gymnastics freerunning and acrobatics
that's just stupid that doesn't even
make sense you idiot parkour is actually
defined as moving through your
environment as quickly and efficiently
as possible
no clips no tricks yeah we're fan for
the show what we were until we saw how
stupid you were and how you made a
stupid mistake and ruined parkour for
everyone of us see what my guys are
doing right here parkour right there
parkour right there parkour right there
parkour right there
don't get it twisted fool
[Applause]
Thank You douche Arama you're very
you're very quick on the uptake first of
all you caught an error we clearly made
in 2002 when I still had a beard
second of all did you videotape that at
a drive-in is that how you got that look
now your claim that parkour isn't full
of flips and tricks is just dead wrong
parkour is full of flips and tricks and
to prove it I got a hold of the actual
inventor of parkour and here is what he
had to say know what up enter a parkour
so apparently this idiots been going
around and saying that he's some type of
parkour expert even though he's just an
idiot he used to be one of my students
and then he tried to room parkour for
everyone by taking out the flips and the
tricks so guess what I kicked him out of
class I said get the flip out of here
and I started a new school the grand
ultimate parkour masters flips and
tricks Academy so here's my lesson plan
check it out okay
day one flips then two tricks then three
flips and tricks the combining me comes
together it's a tough day
then four you're done you're an expert
get it out of here flip right there
tricks right there now turn it around
guys you're through tricks first that's
a trick
there's another trick what
Church right there who's that that's a
referee he's flipping a coin flips right
there the prostitute
turning tricks they continue to get that
stupid on that trip job easy to trick
cereal he flipped right there tricks
reading a fifth birthday treats right
there thank parkour as a final rite of
passage my guys got to do a big flip
right to the face of the biggest city
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so ladies and gentlemen the challenge
still stands if you think you spotted an
error on our show reporter team koco.com
/ ha hi find that ever we will sort it
out right here on the air
[Applause]